احد عشر يوما على كارثه الزلزال والامال
بالعضو بالعثور على احياء تحت الانقاض
بدات تتضائل لا بل انتهت ربما والفرق
الانقاذ في سوريا وتركيا انتقلت الى مرحله
انتشال الجثثمين من تحت الانقاب فرق
الانقاذ ارتدت ملابس العزل والحمايه
لانتشال الجثامين خشيه من انتشار الامراض
والاوبئه بسبب وجود الضحايا تحت الانقاد
كما هو معلوم وكما نشاهد في هاتاي التركيه
لكن الجثث المتبقيه تحت الالقاد ما مصيرها
وهل تحللها سيؤدي الى امراض وتلوث للبيئه
مشاهدينا درجات الحراره المنخفضه الى ما
دون الصفر في تركيا ساهمت حتى الساعه بشكل
كبير الى عدم تحلل الجثث بسرعه وبالتالي
انتشار الامراض لن يشكل خطرا كبيرا الا في
حال بقيت لوقت طويل من دون انتش الها من
تحت الانقاد وافقه طبعا خبراء للصحه وفيما
يتعلق بالرائحه الكريهه المنبعثه من الجثث
تحت الاوقات اكد خبراء الصحه ان الرائحه
التي انتشرت في المناطق المنكوبه مصدرها
الرئيسي شبكه الصرف الصحي التي تضررت بشكل
كامل بعد الزلزال وهذا الامر سيؤدي حتما
الى انتشار الاوبئه في حال لم يتم معالجته
من قبل السلطات بوقت القريب
[موسيقى]